[Music]
you have to get past this firewall up
beep jailbreak should be smooth sailing
from here you're not gonna see that one
around of the cube she's the it girl
enter the password chimichangas aah
Krav Maga Oh gonna blast me every time I
mess up yeah kinda boy I'm a fireball
the emoji movie
welcome to Jeff dan we're gonna have to
dance our way out
I got no groove everybody can dance see
nope she has to stop yeah I see now what
you are saying
I kind of applied to a DS text what
should i do bicho what center an emoji
huh
okay be cool welcome to the secret world
inside your phone
we're emojis like me work and live here
each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time incoming text we are
go for meth
OOP me oh he's making long loose
what is that I've got to get this phone
face this has never happened before and
now alex has made an appointment to wipe
out his phone it's Alex
Dooley llevarlo world gives white girl
I'm not gonna run away from this I made
a mistake but I'm gonna fix it I think
we can make things right we just have to
go to a place where no emoji has gone
before the cloud I know a shortcut
through SMAP but no one's ever left our
city and they'll send BOTS after us
[Music]
what is this place the greatest place
ever
candy crush I'm never eating another
piece of candy again high five don't do
it don't you do it it's already been in
there once you decide this pack the box
I got an idea we're running out of time
before the phone gets white we need to
get the master password access denied
this might take a while wait what access
tonight we're gonna have to dance our
way out everybody can dance see
[Music]